great clouds great skies this morning we
don't see
too many of these lately either and i
want to thank carol biladeau who sent in
her beautiful shot
of the sunrise this morning out on her
morning walk earlier she saw the moon in
the clouds before the sun came up so
really pretty out there
one other clock that maybe you didn't
have a chance to change over the weekend
it's your sprinkler clock because we
went to the winter watering schedule
yesterday
you only get one day a week and we're
looking at
record warmth this week temperatures in
the mid 80s but know your group and
you'll know your one assigned day
today's monday so it's the a group that
gets to water that's it
all right we've got a lot of 60s out
there we've been staying warm because of
the cloud cover
some 50s like perump in the low 50s
laughlin's been a little breezy
kingman and mesquite you just barely
found some upper 50s
the reason for the clouds it's a
disturbance moving up from southern
california we've already had some
lightning up in utah
lincoln county and we're expecting some
lightning storms maybe in our local
mountains
but that's a danger because it could
start some fires without bringing
much rain at all still looking for 83
today well above the norm of low
70s sunshine and mid 80s for election
day tuesday
could see record highs later in the week
windy on friday ahead of a cold front
which will really cool us off for the
weekend 60s on saturday
50s on sunday wow